[Musica]
[Applauso]
sapete perché sono qui sono qui perché
sono finito in galera
a 60 anni da incensurato ho commesso un
reato grave
e mi sono costituito
e con le mie lauree con i miei
pubblicazioni scientifiche i miei
brevetti i miei partecipazioni ai
congressi internazionali i miei viaggi
intorno al mondo sono finito dentro
e sono finito in carcere convintissimo
di sapere ciò che avrei trovato
perché di detenzione mi ero occupato
tantissimo anche se non era il mio
mestiere Io sono fisico ma avevo letto
tanti libri anche specialistici di
sociologia visto film documentario
interviste
credevo di essere perfettamente a
conoscenza di cosa fossero detenzione e
soprattutto
ero convintissimo di sapere quale fosse
il grave problema del carcere italiano
Ovvio Il problema è la carenza di
diritti umani dei detenuti ed detenuti
sono trattati in modo inumano Questa è
una cosa che condividono in tanti in
Italia non tantissimo sono in tanti ad
essere convinti di questo che i detenuti
siano trattati in maniera disumana
tantissimi di più sono convinti del
contrario che detenuti siano trattati
troppo bene Pane acqua e buttare via la
chiave bene Io sono stato in carcere ho
cambiato idea
ma non perché non ci siano violazioni
dei diritti umani tutt'altro il carcere
è un posto tremendo e non è un caso se i
detenuti si uccidono e si suicidano
venti volte più che non è Libertà 20
volte e quando non riescono a suicidarsi
si tagliano si infliggono delle
mutilazioni sbattono la testa al muro
soprattutto i più deboli per loro il
carcere è un inferno Dunque i diritti
umani non vengono rispettati ma se dico
che non è questo il problema allora il
problema qual è
Il problema è che il carcere non
funziona
A che cosa serve il carcere cosa
dovrebbe fare il carcere
ce lo dice la nostra Costituzione
le pene
devono tendere alla rieducazione del
condannato che è una cosa logica
hai violato la legge
bisogna combinarti una penna Ma cosa
deve servire la pena farti ridire una
persona onesta così fa i tuoi anni
Dopodiché
finisce la pena e rientri nella società
come una persona normale come una
persona onesta il carcere fa questa cosa
Ma assolutamente no
recidiva al 70%, Cosa vuol dire che su
ogni 10 detenuti che scontano la pena in
carcere 7 escono dell'inngono di nuovo
ritornano in carcere ogni centro
detenuti 70 escono e ritornano in
carcere perché hanno commesso altri
reati ogni mille 1700 ritorno ogni
10.000
7.000 escono commettono Dei delitti e
ritornano in carcere in carceri ci sono
delle 50.000 alle 60 mila persone
facciamoci un po' di conti
e quanto ci costa ci costa 3 miliardi di
euro all'anno per me che ho 70 anni sono
6000 miliardi delle vecchie lire un
tempo con una cifra del genere si faceva
una finanziaria
E allora
ma possibile perché non vi riepiloghiamo
perché spendiamo questi soldi per
prendere delinquenti lasciarli un po' di
tempo in carcere tenerli fuori ancora
delinquenti in maniera tale che poi
dobbiamo ancora arrestare spendere un
sacco di soldi e rimettere dentro ma non
si potrebbe educarli Certo A questo
punto la domanda è Questi signori
vogliono essere educati non sarà
possibile rieducare un delinquente
oppure non c'è niente da fare per i
delinquenti
7000 ogni 10.000 restano delinquenti
per rispondere a questa domanda
Partirò da una cosa importantissima da
un paio di mutande sporche io sono
entrato in carcere alle due del mattino
ed erano due giorni che viaggiavano
Quando sono entrato in carcere mi hanno
fatto allungare le braccia e sulle
braccia mi hanno messo una coperta due
lenzuola una federa due ciotole
d'acciaio come quelle che si usano per
dare da mangiare e da bere ai cani
una forchetta e un cucchiaio di
alluminio un bicchiere di plastica una
minuscola saponetta da hotel
uno spazzolino usa e getta e un tubetto
di dentifricio che si esauriva in una
volta in cella aveva un gran bisogno di
lavarmi di cambiarmi
Ma le due del mattino non c'è acqua
calda e poi non in tutte le Celle c'è la
doccia anzi nella maggior parte dei casi
c'è la doccia di reparto la doccia di
reparto la si usa nel giorno della
doccia Per cui se sei fortunato e
finisci in cella nel giorno della doccia
ti fai la doccia sennò aspetti il giorno
dopo O due giorni dopo Chi lo sa nel
giorno della doccia
Ma se anche avessi avuto la possibilità
di farla questa doccia come mi sarei
dovuto asciugare ricordate forse se
anche vi ho detto che mi hanno dato un
asciugamano no mi hanno dato dello
shampoo no mi hanno dato della
biancheria di ricambio No adesso è del
mattino non ero mai stato in carcere che
da un poliziotto di turno Mi scusi ma
come faccio a lavarmi Ci penso io e se
ne va e torna dopo due minuti con questo
con un modulo
la domandina semplice il cuore del
carcere modello 393 dell'amministrazione
penitenziaria se sei un detenuto e voi
esercitati un diritto Devi compilare il
modulo e consegnarlo al poliziotto il
quale non prendere lo mette in tasca
naturalmente questo signore stava per
darmelo poi mi ha guardato ero allibito
allora si è rivolto a un altro detenuto
gli ha detto senti questo non so come si
fa fallo tu per lui e questo poverino
che scrivevamo la pena c'è scritto Io
sottoscritto Sergio api siedo di andare
alla Caritas perché non ho niente e ho
imparato la prima lezione carcere mi sta
riducando effettivamente il carcere
educazione Se hai bisogno di qualcosa
Non ti rivolgere al poliziotto Non ti
rivolgere allo stato perché tanto il
poliziotto ti manda da un delinquente
come te
questa domandina non funziona è chiaro
che non funziona è un metodo per legarsi
dalle tasche E tutti quei detenuti che
continuano a chiedere una cosa che
l'altra Tanto si sa più o meno quello
che si può ottenere Ed infatti io che
cosa ho fatto andare alla Caritas non è
compilare la domandina e un'ora dopo
andare alla Caritas come c'è il giorno
della doccia c'è il giorno della Caritas
che può capitare una volta alla
settimana una volta le dieci giorni una
volta al mese chi lo sa e non è che
perché hai fatto la domanda ci vai Hai
fatto la domanda ti metti in fila magari
c'è una fiera lunghissima in carcere
Tutti hanno bisogno della Carità
e se avessi dovuto aspettare un mese
cerchi e Aspettate un mese per avere un
asciugamano cosa ho fatto Sono andato da
un ragazzo che collaborava alla
distribuzione della Caritas e gli ho
detto Senti io ho bisogno di lavarmi mi
puoi dare una mano ti do una mano e mi
ha fatto saltare la fila una settimana
dopo aveva un asciugamano e il cambio di
biancheria un paio di ciabatte per fare
la doccia un paio di scarpe di pessima
qualità ma meglio di niente e una tuta
tre tagli più grandi della mia
perché li ho avuti perché ho imbrogliato
c'era qualcuno che aveva più diritto di
me lui non si è lavato io sì
il carcere è tutto così hai bisogno di
mangiare ti devi mettere d'accordo con
altri delinquenti per mangiare Cioè non
hai soldi per pagartelo
Che cosa vuol dire questo che mi ha
mandato dall'altro delinquente mi ha
mandato il poliziotto
il poliziotto cosa ti dice quando entra
in carcere siete tutti delinquenti
mettetevi d'accordo Basta che non vi
ammazzate tra di voi che non ci è
ammazzati Non vi ammazzate per il resto
arrangiatevi che entra in carcere non fa
altro che fare una vita da delinquente
insieme ad altri delinquenti e te lo
dicono proprio loro i poliziotti
chiedi a lui lui non sa come si fa ma
pensaci tu che non sa può sembrare una
sciocchezza ma
esegue il ragazzo che mi ha fatto
saltare la fila
In modo tale che qualcun altro che aveva
più diritto di meno si è lavato Io sì mi
avesse detto senti guarda io ti ho fatto
il favore Ma tu me lo ricambio le vedi
Queste cinque bustine
Quando vai a prenderti l'asciugamano
consegnare quel ragazzo che ti dà
l'asciugamano gli avrei potuto dire di
no ma no che non avrei potuto Ma quando
mai
il carcere è fatto così se non sei un
delinquente farai bene a diventarlo e
anche in fretta perché se non diventi un
delinquente in fretta
Cosa ho detto prima ci si ammazza 20
volte di più che in libertà ora
ma non è una cosa Idiota
cioè Noi spendiamo 3 miliardi di euro
per prendere delinquenti che sono
delinquenti e quindi vanno in carcere
poi facciamo in maniera che diventino
ancora più delinquenti o comunque
restino delinquenti Come erano dopodiché
li tiriamo fuori
e ci stupiamo se ogni mille delinquenti
700 sono ancora delinquenti ma dovremo
stupirci che quei 30 o 300 o 3000 che
invece non lo sono perché carcere ti
costringe ad essere delinquente
non ci sono vie d'uscita Io sono in
carcere ho avuto paura come tutti ma il
sentimento più profondo era una
terribile rabbia una stizza ne sono ma
si può essere così idioti spendiamo 3000
3 miliardi di euro per generare degli
altri delinquenti che vanno continuano a
fare delinquenti non ci sarà una
soluzione
avevo appena finito di contare la pena
che riceva una telefonata
completa di Cagliari mi dice Ciao Sergio
Lo sai io ho fondato da 25 anni una
comunità di recupero per detenuti
anziché ascoltare la pena in carcere
questi vengono scontano la pena da me
e non sono Ladri di polli sono assassini
efferati assassini
sono stupratore
sono quelli che incidono i bambini i
pedofili
Eppure
su 100 che vengono da me soltanto
quattro di vincono di nuovo
gli ho detto Ma mi stai dicendo quattro
o 40 perché io ero abituato al 70 no 4 e
secondo me siccome ci conoscono in pochi
sarebbe bene che ci conoscessero un po'
di più ho pensato che sarebbe bello
scrivere un libro perché non lo scrivi
tu conosci già in carcere viene da noi
stai Un po' con noi così vedi come
lavoriamo e scrivi un libro cioè mi
stava chiedendo di tornare in galera
perché lui la chiama comunità Ma quei
detenuti lì non sono liberi e la galera
è un posto dove non si libera e lì non
sono liberi per farla breve ho preso un
aereo sono andato da loro sono stato un
po' e ho scritto questo libro
non ne posso parlare troppo ma
Lasciatemi dire che si intitola chi
sbaglia paga perché io sono
convintissimo che Chi commette un
delitto debba rimettersi a posto con la
società e il sottotitolo
del libro
e anche certezza della pena perché
secondo me la pena ascoltata tutta
ma certezza della pena e della
rieducazione perché voi potete dare
tutti gli anni che volete un detenuto Ma
se non lo rieducate tutti quegli anni
non servono a niente perché se lui esce
ed è ancora un delinquente e potete dare
10 anni 12 15 anche per aver rubato una
gallina bene tanto dopo 15 anni avete
tra i piedi ancora un altro delinquente
come funziona questo posto
nel carcere quello che ho fatto io non
si lavora si ozia però perché i detenuti
non vogliono lavorare non si lavora
perché non è possibile perché il carcere
non è previsto per avere dei Lavoratori
sono il 3% delle ore possibilmente
sfruttabili in carcere viene usato per
lavorare e se non si lavora Cosa si fa
Si Acquisiscono pessime abitudini che si
corica le tre del mattino ci si alza
alle 11:30 tanto non c'è niente da fare
in quest'altro carcere invece si entra
soltanto se si lavora
per cui è impossibile avere cattive
abitudini
e gli orari sono scanditi dal lavoro
come capita per tutti noi che lavoriamo
la mattina ci si alza e siccome lì e
detenuti lavorano in una tenuta agricola
vanno a lavorare nei campi ritornano
preparano il pranzo lavano i piatti di
pomeriggio vanno a lavorare nei campi
televisione praticamente non ce n'è
perché la sera quando si torna si sta
anche bisogna fare la cena forse una
mezz'oretta dopo cena mai televisione
accesa durante i pasti si parla si
interagisce
in carcere si mangia il peso dello Stato
Siccome non si lavora non c'è un reddito
La maggior parte della gente in carcere
non ho una lira Pardon Non ha un euro e
quindi sono mantenuti dallo Stato e per
questo si vendica un paio di mutande
Voglio andare alla Caritas qui
si paga il proprio mantenimento ciascun
detenuto ha uno stipendio e 30 % verso
nella cassa comune e mangia quindi non è
qualcuno che gli dava ma non c'è
qualcuno che gli dà da mangiare si paga
il cibo e guarda un po'
ci si compra un paio di mutande non c'è
bisogno di andare alla Caritas non c'è
bisogno di andare dal detenuto ed è per
favore fammi saltare la si fa una vita
normale
e ci si basa sui rapporti di forza e si
obbedisce agli ordini del più forte in
carcere Se ha paura del detenuto più
cattivo di te ma si ha paura anche del
poliziotto e per quello che in carcere
si sta tranquilli si vive nella paura
tra delinquenti e in questo carcere si
aderisce
al convincimento dell'educatore
l'educatore in questo carcere qua è un
collega di lavoro
che va in questo carcere fa parte di una
cooperativa di cui fa parte anche
l'educatore l'educatore la mattina
si limita a dare ordini come farebbe un
poliziotto in carcere dice Guarda oggi
andiamo a portare le viti
prendiamo le cesoie hai le tue cesoies
andiamo guarda Si fa così
Poi resta un educatore poi si obbedisce
ma il rapporto è completamente diverso
e in carcere si è chiuso in gabbia e
nell'altro carcere non ci sono piani
perché non ci sono chiare perché per
entrare Lì uno deve auto convincersi di
dover scontare una pena quindi non fugge
in 30 anni in quel carcere non c'è mai
stato un solo tentativo di fuga
e naturalmente nel carcere contenitivo
non c'è attività culturale Ma quando mai
non si fa niente in quest'altro carcere
invece si partecipa attivamente
all'attività culturale sono fondamentali
per la rieducazione e naturalmente nel
carcere normale C'è poca interazione
sociale con chi interagisce il
delinquente con altri delinquenti oppure
quei poliziotti e invece qua no proprio
per le attività culturali C'è un sacco
di gente che va in quel carcere lì poi
detenuti resta dentro Ma conoscono un
sacco di gente
e naturalmente il carcere c'è la
violazione dei diritti umani come
sarebbe possibile Altrimenti prendete un
cumulo di delinquenti che mettete
insieme li fate guardare a vista dai
poliziotti Ma come si fa a non avere
relazioni invece perché il rispetto dei
diritti umani è una parte della
rieducazione
per finire perché il carcere non
funziona perché è pieno di poliziotti
c'è un poliziotti due dei detenuti e un
educatore anni 80 ma in certe carceri è
un educatore di 200 mentre in
quest'altro carcere qui non ci sono i
poliziotti e c'è un educatore ogni due
detenuti Ecco perché li rieducano perché
un carcere fatto per rieducare e guarda
un po' il carcere normale Cosa 140 euro
al giorno perde detenuto e questo costa
la metà €70
recidiva 70% recidiva 4
questo non è un miracolo è semplicemente
un carcere fatto per educare che
dimostra che è possibile rieducare i
carcerati e In definitiva
Qualunque sia il vostro orientamento
politico
chiedete ai vostri rappresentanti quelli
che votate un carcere che funzioni cioè
che punisca rieducando secondo
Costituzione non come quella attuale che
non rieduca e se vi diranno che non è
possibile dite loro che non è vero
perché c'è chi da 30 anni lo fa e lo fa
anche bene spendendo la metà
rispettando i diritti umani
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]